d'accord Ray d'accord tu es prêt
beaucoup de gens qui sont neurodivergents
ont été sur-thérapeutés c'est un
endroit où ils peuvent venir tu n'as pas à
t'inquiéter que tu saches qu'ils doivent le faire de
cette façon
c'est une libération c'est un physique
libération émotionnelle mentale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont affaire à une société qui
n'est pas nécessairement adaptée à cela, donc j'appelle
cela une évolution Révolution
[Musique]
merci
scintille
est
maintenant prêt pour votre deuxième fois à
l'étranger
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr, il y a des moments où je me sens
dépassé et juste fatigué, vous savez, alors
j'essaie juste de me rappeler que je ne suis pas
seul,
c'est que
vous savez quand vous pensez que quelque chose ne va pas,
mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment sûr et  tu
es peut-être un peu dans le déni
il n'était pas
certain des jalons c'est
vrai
il ne parlait pas il ne faisait pas de contact visuel
on lui a diagnostiqué qu'il était sur le
spectre de l'autisme
quand il avait environ deux ans et demi
pouvez-vous m'aider
[Musique]
aide  moi
non maman
oh wow
tu ne me frappes pas tu frappes ce regard
tu vas frapper la boxe le sac de boxe
regarde
va frapper le sac de boxe va frapper le
sac de boxe ouais tu devrais mettre tes
gants pour le faire non d'accord tu ne '  tu
n'aimes pas mettre les gants tu n'aimes pas les
gants
quand Rey a été diagnostiqué ils ont dit qu'il
cherchait des sens il aimait le bruit
de la porte qui claque est-ce que tu aimes ça je
pense que c'est tellement drôle tu penses que c'est tellement
drôle c'est un sentiment très sensible  il
aime les miroirs il aimait être poussé ça le
fait se sentir bien et ça le
centre aussi et certains parents ne
veulent pas que leurs enfants soient étiquetés
et je ne le vois pas comme ça je vois comme
lui étiqueter ce que tu veux comme
[Musique]
Je m'en fiche de l'appeler comme vous voulez
tant qu'il obtient les
ressources dont il a besoin si cela signifie
être dans une salle de classe plus petite, ce qui signifie
suivre une
ergothérapie orthophonie peu importe
[Musique]
ouais le  la caméra doit voir ça c'est une
super chanson
bien prête
hé tu vas vouloir attraper ça tu
peux euh dire tu peux je
dis
tu ne peux pas dire wow
[Musique]
euh je suis la mère d'Oliver euh il a huit
ans
euh il a été diagnostiqué quand  il avait probablement
quatre ans, vous savez, nous avons un jumeau, il est jumeau
euh
et euh ouais ça a été une
aventure
bon travail Bobby
merci mesdames et messieurs c'était un
spectacle agréable ce soir ouais
il a quelque chose de spécial
qu'il a juste qui se connecte  avec
les gens
euh je pense aussi à sa douceur innocente
d'accord mon pote Jessica dis le dans
tes yeux pousse ouais ouais je pense euh ouais
et son humour je veux dire c'est définitivement
il nous fait rire tout le temps j'aime
lutter avec lui
normalement c'est celui qui gagne  même s'il
va à la boxe
ce que je suis le gagne la raison pour laquelle je l'ai même
inscrit l'a cherché parce qu'il
était vraiment bon pour battre son
frère comme aujourd'hui quelqu'un demande
ce qu'est l'autisme l'autisme est quelque chose
comme quand comme vous voyez comme  ce que j'explique
beaucoup, mais si tout
cela n'expliquerait pas grand-chose
parce qu'il serait comme regarder autour de lui, il est
comme s'il aime ne
sait même pas que tu es là comme debout
là mais il  en quelque sorte fait
une bonne façon de l'expliquer merci tu joues
juste c'est ta classe
euh ouais c'est vraiment bon mon pote je suis
vraiment fier de toi il sait ce qu'il
fait mais il ne sait pas non plus ouais
je sais ce que je fais  beaucoup et
parfois je n'ai pas raison donc c'est
quelque chose que nous avons en commun
c'est une chose
et nous aimons aussi les animaux c'est une autre
chose
[Applaudissements]
mais parfois quand il danse il est
comme me frapper hey j'arrêterai
Ollie qui ne danse pas
oh
[  Applaudissements]
ok
allez Cassius
ok ok ok ok ok ok
[Musique]
Je sais que vous jouez mais toujours
prêts
[Musique] ok non non
non vous savez pourquoi parce qu'alors ils
doivent le nettoyer et ces gars avec qui ils
travaillent vraiment dur  nettoyez le verre alors
ne mettez pas votre bouche là oh ne
vous frappez pas c'est bon
vous n'êtes pas en difficulté mais ne recommencez pas
les enfants sur le spectre
je pense qu'il y a comme un dicton tu sais que
je suis autiste soyez patient
d'accord
s'il le frappe
[Musique]
pour regarder mais aussi je comprends qu'il est juste
frustré c'est comme si tu lui parlais une
langue différente c'est
comme si l'autisme c'est comme si c'était bien
si tu es en colère ne te frappe pas
c'est comme  allez frapper ce sac de boxe juste
là, vous savez
la première fois que je l'ai emmené, nous sommes entrés
et je vous jure qu'il avait l'air et c'est comme si
les yeux s'illuminaient
et c'était presque comme si j'avais finalement
trouvé un endroit aussi bruyant et  il se passe beaucoup de choses,
je ne veux pas dire fou, mais
vous savez comme moi, vous
savez ce sentiment où vous êtes comme
wow
deux coups de poing de ce côté
[Musique]
cela augmente la concentration cela réduit l'anxiété en
découvrant aussi qu'ils ont une certaine
puissance physique
disons  allez
tu m'as vu boxer là-bas qu'est-ce que je
pense que je fais ce vieux large venir
ici il y a même des années tu sais que j'ai en fait
eu quelques mouvements
mais en ce moment c'est à propos d'eux nous
allons faire des rafales
maintenant je suis  Je vais donner aux enfants une chance de
m'entraîner ensuite parce que cela montre à quel
point ils savent réellement quand ils
arrivent à tenir les tricots et à
m'entraîner pour que je puisse l'essayer avec Ray Win Je
ne sais pas s'il est prêt pour ça
tiens-les pour moi
d'accord je vais les frapper tiens-les pour
moi tiens-les
là tu vas un deux un deux oui d'
accord tu me dis que tu es le patron d'
accord
pour moi c'est toute une vie parce que j'ai  je l'ai vécu j'ai compris
tu le fais super
boulot tu veux essayer de le refaire avec moi
tu penses que je peux le faire
ouais d'accord c'est bon
j'implore tout le monde d'
écouter différemment ne t'attends pas à ce qu'ils
soient neurotypiques  voici un exercice qui peut
vous apprendre quoi faire quand vous êtes
assommé ça s'appelle qu'est-
ce que tu fais mec
j'aime les lunettes aujourd'hui ce
sont des lunettes 3D que vous obtenez d'un
film L'insistant je les porte
ces derniers temps le fait qu'il  va là-bas il est
salut Amy salut ce salut que je pense que ça l'a
aidé socialement oui
[Musique]
ils lui permettent il portait souvent beaucoup de
costumes en allant là-bas
ça lui a permis de s'exprimer parce
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment communiquer autant qu'il
le voudrait  c'est comme ça que vous l'avez compris,
quel que soit l'isolement que les gens pensent que quelqu'un
est neurodivergent,
ne présumez pas aussi
vite que d'autres enfants que j'ai jamais
formés, alors faites-le
bien, que choisissons-nous un bon travail en
disant s'il vous plaît faites votre argent wow
dire merci merci
ouais
continuez à vous concentrer sur le bien partout où vous
pouvez continuer à être vous c'est bon vous avez
le droit d'être parfait être parfaitement
imparfait peu importe quelqu'un qui va
vous accepter c'est chaleureux continuez là
où il fait chaud continuez à trouver que tout
va bien saisir  tes gants pour moi d'accord
il est heureux clairement tu vois à quel point il est heureux tu
sais je suis reconnaissant je l'ai
point
je sais que nous sommes sur la bonne voie
[Musique]